[Music]
from his bilingual from guadalajara austral
that I have left
[Music]
louis
one the pioneers was rafael caro
quintero
yes
gmail
4 now it's cold de guadalajara cartel
using the roads guadalajara to send
rocks the united states special and
marijuana
[Music]
h
[  Music]
I start hanging out with expensive quintero you know
why the giant contra broadcast says
because the drug traffickers came
and took away the best girls they
brought the best horses
ryan the belt was pitted the fine shirts
would be the boots
[Music]
all I wish for was a  poor
ragged man with huaraches that
guy sells motta because I don't
rafael he started selling tons
like seeing a lot of money
[Applause]
brufau de
[Music]